but
um what's changed though
um well and also my question to you is
is that because I believe that I
wouldn't change anything of my past
because everything that happened led up
to this moment and I love my life now
right so it's like did all those events
need to happen for me to become a
comedian did it I mean I questioned
these things I mean do you think that
that but how how good would your life be
if you didn't get naked every day in
front of people like
like you you don't know I don't do that
anymore man then what jokes are you
going
I got I got switches and stuff on my app
now man yeah I mean I used to love
walking into a comedy club and I just
walk in the back of the room oh Bobby's
naked and you're doing the man John huh
yeah yeah yeah Manchester one time I
remember my brother was out visiting me
in Vegas and that's when they used to do
that that Playboy Comedy Club yeah and I
was just in Vegas just I wasn't digging
or anything I was just with my brother
in Vegas and they used to pull that
curtain because it was sometimes just a
Cabaret Bar in the corner yeah they
pulled curtain they call it the Playboy
Lounge there's one girl in a bunny
outfit you know yeah anyway so so they
they you were I go I go oh they go I go
who's on tonight your Marquee was out
the front they go I know this guy
I know this guy we'll come and watch him
and you just had your dick out and was
sitting on the lap of some fat person in
the front row and then my brother's like
a closer this is your friend is that I
go I know him
[Laughter]
ah yeah yeah I know but I didn't even
see her I walked in I went all right
let's go do whatever with it but the
worst one I had was this I was at uh
Caroline's yeah and one night it was
raining the terrible I was eating it
with my jokes and so I get naked wait a
minute wait a minute it was raining
Caroline's is a basement Club how does
the rain play into this people it was a
stormy night it was stormy and people
didn't come oh oh okay that's what
happened okay right right it wasn't it
didn't affect the mood of the audience
it was just like you know if they said
you sold out but only half the room was
there and it was a dreadful night sure
and I closed with this thing where I got
naked right it ate it worse than the
jokes like they were it's seemed
desperate I think you should still keep
getting I'm being seriously I I always
like that you got naked it was something
bold about it and also I know if I start
doing that I get canceled right away I
get cancer right away but your
grandfathered in as he's been nude for
years oh you think I'm grandfather today
you can show your dick to anyone that's
what I think
I'm thinking about it wow you know I've
been that's what but let me finish the
story yeah yeah yeah so I'm eating it
right I thought that was the story no no
it gets worse so I gather up my clothes
right and I'm walking toward the back
and I see somebody leaning against the
wall in front of the Green Room it was
Chris Rock right and he and he's naked
not naked and he looks at me and he goes
what are you doing man oh and I remember
going I don't know and I walked in the
Green Room Chris Rock always says
everything twice what are you doing what
are you doing
that's how we said it it was it was I
remember that distinctly that night it
was a horrible night anyway what were
you gonna say
um it never comes off sexual when when I
when you get naked oh yeah when I'm
naked it's very sexual awkwardly so yeah
yeah hemorrhoids hanging out my [__]
I didn't buy that no it's like when I
see you
neighbor right also it's like a silly
childlike
um I just don't I feel like being 51 and
behaving in that great for 51. thanks
buddy I appreciate it I just feel like
it's just not my thing anymore it feels
weird for me
like I don't do it on stage it's like I
I just you know I just feel like I have
I've grown past it that's like me you're
not wearing leather jackets anymore
exactly the same thing you don't wear
leather jackets I still wear them every
now and again yeah sometimes I got a
whole wardrobe with leather jackets and
then sometimes I'll put one on just to
go out and I'm like [__] you look like
Jim Jefferies right now like that's
annoying like it's just it was one of
those branded things I'll tell you my
favorite leather jacket story right